I was playing a game on the Internet
chess server today where my opponent did
an unbelievably bad thing or rather put
another way he allowed an unbelievably
bad thing to happen
he got a bishop that was essentially
trapped and out of the game forever and
it amazes me how often times this type
of play occurs okay so for example we're
going to play we're gonna move just
their group make some room over here
this is very very common between
inexperienced players who will play an
opening we call this opening the four
Knights yeah the four Knights opening
white develops his Knights black
develops his Knights white develops his
bishop black develops an issue if you go
to a scholastics chess tournament for
example you'll see 5,000 children that
is scholastics Chess Championship and
probably a third of the her playing
disposition because their coaches have
told them that you develop your Knights
first you occupy the center with a pawn
and then you develop your bishops and
you castle quickly okay so here we go
castles quickly yes now normally you
would like to see black castle quickly
but in this particular case we're going
to say that black is the less
experienced player and he ends up
playing
which is a kind of cool move when you
when you think about it you pin the
night to whites Queen given the
opportunity you will love to play your
Knight d4 and end up capturing this
knight forcing like to have double pawns
and really weak weakened White's King
its position so we're going to go h3
we're going to drop back with the bishop
and we're getting closer and closer to
the position I want to achieve we're
gonna play g4 for white now this is a
very radical decision by white because
he his king the king is on the King side
and he's thrust his pawn shield forwards
and potentially endangered his King for
the rest of the game now a very good
move here for black is to capture this
pawn so what has happened after this
capture this double capture is that
black has sacrificed a knight for two
pawns but not just any pawn pawns that
are very important for the shelter of
whites King that if you aren't paying
attention blacks threat is to play 90
for the inexperienced player he says
after g4 I'm not gonna give up my night
for two pawns because of Knights were
three two pawns worth - I don't want to
be behind my opponent's really stronger
than me or
whatever it is instead I'll drop back
with the bishop okay and black reasons
that my goodness he's perfectly safe no
problem and white and it is true white
has taken liberties with his palm
position again we're talking about two
players here not very experienced white
plays 95
okay so black panics black panics he in
blacks mind he had played this Bishop
pin and he wanted to play Knight here
now black panics and thinks that white
is going to pin him and blacks intention
had been to Castle because he knows his
coach says castle get your King out of
danger but now black panics and he
thinks well if I Castle my opponent is
going to pin me just in the way I wanted
to pin him and I'm gonna be dead I'm
gonna be dead my King position is going
to be compromised and man I that that's
got bad news written all over it so
black decides instead to play the move
Queen d7 and with this move what black
reasons is that hey listen if the King
side is a bad area the board that I want
to avoid I'm going to go Queen side so
now this is now we're getting to the
position that I really want to express
we'll see it in a very concrete form now
Knight takes pawn takes Bishop here now
black is very very happy because he
thinks to himself
that white spawns are weak the white
pawns are weak and that his King is
safer than whites King and the truth of
the matter is this is correct
blacks king is indeed for the moment
safer than the white king but there's a
big problem this guy this bishop on g6
is absolutely passive in fact one can
look at that bishop and say it's trapped
and over the course of the game if we
continue for example rook g8 white for
example plays king h2 well white doesn't
necessarily want to do I'm just going to
put another silly move on the board this
is a silly move what white doesn't want
to do is allow this pawn to go here
because now thanks to the rook on g8 the
bishop has been liberated so instead of
allowing the liberation of the bishop on
g6 white place king h2 and essentially
says for the rest of this game no matter
what else happened this Bishop will
never play again the game I refer
referencing to didn't I was against a
grandmaster I was white and I have
played c4 noomane like my opponent has
played c6 I open with the English he
opens up with a Slav I played Knight up
3 he played b5 I put defy pardon me
I played b3 he played night here I like
fianchetto in my bishops obviously as
you can see and he plays what is
popularly called the London system with
the move 8:17
well you might ask yourself what the
heck is this move h7h sex is all about
there's not even Bishop g5 there's a the
idea is to key is to create a cave or a
retreat square if you will for this
Bishop on age set to go to HSM it's it's
a very popular line of play I played
Bishop b2 my opponent played 9b d7 I
played e3 he played Bishop e7 now I
played a kind of a weird little obscure
move it needs a little bit of
explanation it's kind of hard to justify
the most natural square on the board for
this night is to play the Knight to c3
but if we put the knight on c3 we notice
that in this particular pawn structure
where the pawns are on c6 and d5 this
Knights future this Knight doesn't have
a great future it's not going to jump
here it's not gonna jump here it's not
jumping here so I did something a little
bit weird don't do this at home I played
Knight a3 and the idea in this
particular case was to find a better
square for the knight as will become
clear in a moment my opponent has castle
I have played Knight here my opponent
played pawn here don't ask me why I
played Queen here wanna play pawn here I
play pawn bishop here so my idea what
did what did my opponent do here my idea
my opponent did something yes he played
Bishop h7 of course yes yes
yes right I am welcoming any trades
against C for or against b3 but on the
other hand I'm not trying to initiate
them either I think that this pawn is
better than this pawn so I don't trade
these pawns at this moment so my
opponent has played Bishop h7 and I
played the move Queen B - boom boom now
what on earth did he play I think he
played Queen c7 I played b4 now I'm
ready to expand on the Queen side my
opponent played b5 well I said fine I
was ready to expand over here
my opponent played rook here I took
exacta took the Queen went back here I
played a3 my opponent is stuck for a
move he's stuck for a move he would love
to play the move Knight d7 attacking my
bishop but because my Queen and Bishop
make this battery quite unpleasant 97 is
simply met by Bishop take g7 capturing
upon worse from my opponent's point of
view my opponent is thinking oh my
goodness I have to be careful remember
this mysterious Knight move that I
didn't put my knight here I put the
night here my opponent is starting to
worry that I will put my knight here
with a very powerful idea of capturing
so my opponent wanted to solve very very
badly
this pressure on the diagonals so he
first played the move Bishop f8 in order
to preface his intention of ninety seven
to chase away my bishop now here I
immediately went for the bishops the
bishop trap idea as we can see I played
oops sorry I played here okay
so start to notice what is about to
happen to this bishop you have to be
very very careful bishops are great in
open positions in closed positions they
could end up getting themselves cornered
or trapped my opponent has played Bishop
e7 I have played f4 he has taken I have
taken he's played rook here
I played rook here my opponent is afraid
of the move Knight to d4 attacking this
pawn followed by E 5 what opening up
this bishop so my opponent played the
move e you get only one guess as to what
I played f5 absolutely fi ya now in the
barbaric Northwest we call this a septic
bishop
that Bishop belongs in the toilet that
is a really really really bad Bishop
remember in the first example I had the
bishop was on the bishop was on g6 but
in this example the bishop is on h7 now
this is really cool and I'll just show
you the rest of the game quickly rook
takes rook d8 rook takes Bishop takes
now let's take a look at this position
for a second
at first sight you might think well
maybe black can actually draw this game
okay we understand he's a bishop down
like this Bishop can never get back in
the game in fact black would just love
to offer me that epsilon and say here
take this pawn if this f7 pawn didn't
exist
well black could play King here and
bring his Bishop out but boy I was very
happy very happy indeed that my opponent
had this f7 pawn because I knew with an
absolute certainty that I would be
playing the rest of the game a piece up
a bishop ahead but again what I wanted
to draw your attention to was this idea
of like well how can white win
I've talked almost non-stop about how
bad that Bishop is but isn't this Bishop
kind of ugly I mean where on earth I
could move my bishop here to d1 to c2 to
be one to a two and we would all agree
the bishop is well placed on this
diagonal but how am I going to break
through if we imagine my king for a
moment trotting oops
trotting up oops trotting no there's
nowhere to trot but it's an illusion
this is a very very easy winning
position for me and in this position
what I did is I sacrificed a piece
simple
I played Knight here my opponent played
King here
I played bishop here my opponent played
King here I went Knight here
my opponent played King here I went
Knight here because essentially this
fellow I'm playing a piece ahead I can
be very generous when I'm a piece ahead
I can give a piece back my opponent has
played h5 very inspiring move that's I
took no ah that felt better you know
three connected past pawns and they're
going really really really fast a
question a question and a very
legitimate question you may ask me well
it asked me is you might have said yes
sir when you sacrifice your knight
you're going for bishops of opposite
color position didn't teach you fear
that that could be a draw the bishops of
opposite color position and that
wouldn't it have been better for you to
sacrifice your bishop and then take with
the knight come back and take this pawn
and it's a perfectly legitimate question
but a comment but the reality is bishops
of opposite color positions do have a
tendency to be drawn but not when you're
three connected passed pawns ahead I had
no problems going for this bishops of
opposite color I took this pawn my
opponent had a good idea
he activated his bishop I think we got a
position like this
I finally and I have gone here he went
down I went check
he went over I went up up up and here he
know he didn't resign I remember he
played h4 kind of a desperate last fling
I went tanks and here he resigned
because what is happening is when he
moves his Bishop I'm coming with my
connected passed pawns up the board I'm
just going to move my bishop all right
I'm actually going to take this pawn so
that I can go check and then put my
Bishop here so this is what happened but
one of the the strategic ideas that I
wanted to show by these two examples is
how easy it is for a bishop to end up
being ensnared trapped in other words
okay
these are two top grandmasters Nigel
short is on the white side isn't it
funny I was talking about the four
Knight said you know the trapping of a
bishop and look what we get so
this position a cool position right
nothing it's kind of a random cool
position I don't know I mean maybe it's
not even that interesting maybe it's a
blind position for bishops for rooks
Queens 4 4 4 3 you know the game should
probably be a draw and because it looks
so open it's very hard to imagine any
kind of a situation arising like the
strategic idea that I'm talking about
tonight which is a bishop getting
trapped isn't this Bishop going to get
trapped doesn't look at is this Bishop
going to get trapped doesn't look at
this bishop we'll see this is this is
going to take some effort to trap one of
the bishops the grandmasters are very
clever people ok they can do it Bishop
g5 Queen f5 offering a trade of Queens
and I'm sure had white traded Queens
followed by playing say Bishop d3 there
would be many more trades and a draw is
an inevitable outcome Bishop e7 how cool
is that
the vladimir overlook in exchange the
big that the rook look-look-look the
rook the rook is trapped oh my the rook
can't go to e8 of course because Bishop
takes e8 so has Vladimir Kramnik the man
who won the World title from Garry
Kasparov made an elementary blunder is
what do you think do you think it says
do you think
he could have done that yes no I'm not
sure
well Queen takes pawn takes a six was
played Bishop a4 was Nigel's reaction as
we just saw Nigel starts to realize that
wait a minute maybe this exchange that
he's planning on capturing isn't all
it's cracked out to be so for example if
we take the rook right away we'll lose
this bishop the bishop will come back
but then after the move f6
the bishop is trapped on e7 so let's
pardon me I think I did it wrong but let
me just show what would have happened in
case of bits oops that wasn't what I
wanted to do it wait yeah take the rook
sorry new variation take here Bishop
here rook f6
and this bishop is like just fixed it's
prepared after King here this bishop
will eventually lead to a loss for white
kramnik Bishop a4 was played B 5 B 4 ok
attacking that Bishop rook e8 rook e1
Bishop Bishop now we understand that
Nigel
could not have grabbed that exchange
so here Nigel's thinking in his mind's
eye okay I will play c4 I will play a
for a draw is inevitable
Bishop d7 kingi to defending the pot d5
end of game it's over that's it
defy then the game because as we start
to understand the move
d5 we start to ask what on earth is this
the computer may say the positions even
because it doesn't realize that 50 moves
from now this Bishop still hasn't moved
it may not be captured but it can never
escape its confinement and Nigel said in
his post mortem a post interview after
the game is that after you play King g2
and realized that okay once he plays c4
he will liberate his bishop once he's
played the mood King G to saying okay
I'll play c4 make a draw you realize oh
my gosh what if my opponent stops me
from liberating my bishop with c4 and he
said I realized instantly I was lost
d5 rook here c6 the blockade rook bishop
bishop this bishop is trapped that's
what it's all about
a4 Bishop d7 Bishop to a trade see all
black just like the game I showed you
that I play today on the ICC black
essentially is playing the game a piece
ahead this Bishop is out Bishop b3
black white is actually helpless he
can't do anything and all black has
doing is just advancing with this king
notice that White's king is passive and
just tying his opponent down and here
Nigel gave it a rest it didn't matter
that it that he gave it a rest 20 moves
later or 30 moves or he could plate on
another 10 moves or so from here the
point is as the end of the at the end of
the game he still left with a bishop at
the trap Bishop so this strategic idea
of trapping the bishops comes I think
most famously from Capablanca there was
a game of Kappa Blancas where he trapped
his opponents Bishop and the whole point
of today's class is make sure this
doesn't happen to you or if you've got
an opportunity to trap your opponent's
Bishop like Vladimir Kramnik does my
strong advice is do it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]